hey what's up guys welcome to the dope
as usual podcast before we start we want
to talk to you about one of our sponsors
this is better help so this is what
better help is guys
it's basically an online app that you
sign up for
and it's a license of professional
licensed therapist
this is not a crisis help line this is
not a hotline talk this is not anything
like that this is an
actual person that knows what they're
doing they get matched with you
and you have someone so go to
www.betterhelp.com
forward slash dope that gets you 10 off
of your first month of treatment i've
had a lot i mean there's hundreds and
maybe thousands of people dm me talking
about
depression not being well i'm by myself
i have nobody to talk to
i get it man i get it so this is an
outreach it's convenient you don't have
to go to a doctor's office
you can sign up online completely
discreet from your house so remember i
told you this is actual professionals
they have a financial aid there's a
program if you cannot afford this
this is actually reaching out it's
better
help perfect name and what i said
earlier is for depressed people it's not
only for people that are depressed
some people are in really bad
relationships some people have ptsd they
have trauma they don't know where to
turn to
just because like i said sometimes it's
a sensitive subject to talk about
whether you're
a famous dude or your construction
worker you work at mcdonald's
everybody needs someone to talk to and
not everybody has that so check out
[Music]
betterhelp
[Music]
what's up guys dopaziola here hope
you're having a dopest day welcome back
to the dope as usual podcast we're here
to talk about life drugs accomplishments
and everything in between today guys we
have a special guest
before like oh gee i've had my friends
on this podcast before but i have a lot
of friends i'm also going to bring every
one of them on
this is another friend i brought on
because i know
you guys are going to love this story i
think there's a lot to unfold here
so introducing our guest today this is
omar ratchet man ratchet tone whatever
you want to
i don't know what to call you what do we
call you oh whatever you
what whatever out of those three four
what am i calling you ratchet man
let's just stay with ratchet man ratchet
i'm wretched man today
today you're ratchet man yeah today i'm
ratchet man okay you guys the story
starts with ratchet it starts that way
yeah okay so i want to introduce it that
way i know a lot of you if you don't
know
a lot of you guys are my fans so you
already know who ratchet man
is but if you don't know can you give us
a little slight without going into it
what do you do
it's i wouldn't just say musician you do
a lot of [ __ ]
uh i'm i'm i guess i'm i'm all over the
place
you know i just i best word artists
you know there you go i like to do
photography
i can do photoshop stuff my own flyers
my own covers
music uh all around marketing
you know wheat stuff you know everything
anything that
i like i do it pretty much so all around
that's a horrible explanation
[Laughter]
horrible it's so good it's all good um
i'm just all around player you know
and i was about to say that we just
become best friends that [ __ ] didn't say
exactly what
marty says you know i have three kids i
live in irvine you know my wife's a
realtor well you said
fast so i didn't want to go into that
you're good you're good you're good
uh let's let's get into detail where did
you grow up because you have a san
francisco uh hat on i'm gonna make fun
of you all day
san francisco head on right now but
you're not from the bay i'm not from the
bay which is fine we're in california
yeah i know but the base shows me a lot
of love and i don't deal with the whole
like neither do i politics or baseball
before we started that's why i said it
before we started people like why you
got a
frisco head on you were in la yeah hey i
wear la stuff and i'm from merced
uh yeah it's california love guys it's
definitely all the way across
the bay has is awesome bro when i went
to the bay
the weather was nice and cold super cold
to the jackets
yeah you can wear jackets you know what
i'm saying and i love being in the cold
i'm like a polar bear so i'm here
i love the cold that's one i first tried
cookies for the first time
in the bay and i fell in love you know
that's like way before the whole
girl scout cookies yeah yeah so like
they used to call it cooks in the bay
you know everybody's like yo that cooks
you smell it in skate parks and i'll be
like
dude where's that coming from and it was
my first time in the bay so
er when i you know smoked the cooks and
the bed i just fell in love with the
city and everything like
i have homies that there live there you
know frisco's tired yeah so she's a
crystal
yeah frisco showed me love and i you
know i was going back
and forth because of work you know so
frisco showed me a lot of love so i love
to rep the bass so i [ __ ] like
i i don't do the whole la sf [ __ ] of
course it was
a [ __ ] talk but are not from so where
are you from uh i am born and raised
since
um i'm from l.a you know born and raised
i was born in south central
king hospital the worst hospital in
south central ever you know
yeah i mean people like there's stories
where people don't even make
it when they go there like type you know
you can do your research king hospital
martha luther king hospital i think he
closed it too
yeah it's in south central somewhere
merced yeah it's
a ghetto hospital back in the day but um
i grew up there i mean
my whole family grew up in south central
my mom
went to uh burendo middle school and
like
i i ended up like going by like middle
school
i was like in echo park i was just
jumping around everywhere you know we
trying to find our spot you know
and then i just end up growing up i
would say the rest
from like high school like middle school
actually like sixth grade to like
the rest of my life i would say east
hollywood like normandy
between normandy and western and
hollywood type
i know you don't know but out of the
streets of the streets yeah
around here between normandy and west
you know
get out of here bro we had so many
friday references the other day
of course i know what you're talking
about yeah so i i lived literally east
hollywood hollywood and normandy
is it ghetto over there uh it actually
is man you think hollywood is pretty but
it's
not man like you know like you have to
deal with
growing up with like different gangs in
different sides you know
like like anywhere else you know like
there's gangs everywhere but like
east hollywood they were everywhere and
they were like neighbors they were
trying to take over their territory it
was just
all scattered you know what i'm saying
and i was like in the middle of it you
know
growing up but i really didn't even care
because i was a musician i was always
like [ __ ] all that because seeing my dad
you know like
my uncles and everybody like in that
lifestyle was like
man [ __ ] that [ __ ] you know like also i
i you said there's like gang here this
game this game because i never grew up
with that because merced
is small yeah you're either the one
or you're the one that got pushed out
there's not a lot of gangs unless it's a
race thing
and then it's like oh there's sub gangs
yeah no but i never had to worry about
that everybody just wore red if you wore
blue you got shot at yeah
yeah that's from merced but from over
here like you and og talking about well
there's them and they controlled this
yeah and they control this block yeah so
you had to deal with those politics
growing up as a kid you know
like even though you had nothing to do
with it you know
you have to deal with the other guys
from the other block coming to your
block and be like where are you guys
from you're like bro i just live here
you know like i don't [ __ ] gangbang
or nothing
but that's part of l.a culture you know
that's part of growing up
i guess that's part of everyone's in la
if you grew up in l.a
you had to deal with that if you didn't
then maybe
uh i don't know your parents went to
school yeah or you were at private
school or
some [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] know you know
what i'm saying or your dad and mom
dropped you off every day you know
like we had to take the bus so those are
the
the times where you're in the back of
the bus like what's up get out of there
like what
i'm not getting out of my seat bro you
know like the [ __ ] out of here but
it you know you deal with that growing
up in la so it's kind of normal you know
it's like the norm
in l.a but yeah i grew up in east
hollywood long story short
all right so um you talked about it
earlier you're trying to
say this artist all around i do this a
creative is what it really is
creative you wrote a book right how long
ago was that
uh that was probably like five years ago
it was more like a zine book
you know what does that mean uh it's
more like pictures and like
the coffee table yeah yeah like a coffee
table what was it
what was it called uh it was called los
malos and it was
pretty much a story of my background of
my like my dad
like my dad's been in prison since 1991
so like he used to send me polaroids
art pictures even the crafts they did
like cups
all kinds of stuff you know that they
had their
chance to get inside so i would collect
all this stuff
through years of like years due to like
twice so 91 19 so you never hung out
with your dad ever
not really because when you're [ __ ]
four years old yeah and when he came out
he uh your dad got out he got out once
that i remember you know he thought he's
been in the whole time he got out
once and then like literally like not
even a month or two he went straight
back in
you know and i remember like getting my
first super nintendo he's like yo i got
something for you
and it was like he i guess he went to go
hit a lick or something
and he had super nintendo with uh mario
and [ __ ] street fighter
and then he's like yeah i got you this
and that's how i got my first super
nintendo
[ __ ] on the time he was out yeah the
time he was out and like it was crazy
because he would live like not even
three blocks away from my mom
like and at that time we were staying in
koreatown you know
and i could literally like uh go like
around the block three blocks and i can
go to his house
and uh one time i remember i went
unexpectedly and he had a kickback and
everything my mom was so
mad because there was all these girls in
there like that's what you're [ __ ]
doing here you're [ __ ]
but yeah but you know he was just that
was his time out you know so i guess he
was wilding out
but he went back in so then after that
just
been and he's been there forever now
yeah i think so man i think he's lost
in the system you know it's one of those
type of situations because what i heard
is that
if you get locked up around the 90s or
like 91 and up
you're like literally considered like
one of like the main dudes
of like starting into the whole mafia
scene or whatever the [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying like
i don't get really too deep in it but i
know that
it's he's in that system you know like
he's
in that definitely category that's first
and then you guys
yeah yeah like he's in there like so i
was like uh
whatever you know so i kept in touch man
but it's just
one of those things where you could only
do so much you grow up
you know you're like [ __ ] that you know
i don't want to get involved in them
i mean it's not like oh i don't care
about you it's more of i can't be
associated with your game-banging ass
yeah because i'm trying to i'm trying to
live my life good yeah exactly it's not
like he's a bad person just no no being
associated with you
anybody in the law is going to go what
the [ __ ] are you doing there yeah yeah
what are you doing
what are you getting them what do you
say yeah or what you should send them
some money
oh what do you do what do you do for him
exactly that's one of those things and
then at those times at that time
i was you know becoming this ratchet man
you know
like being the artist and you know
trying to get out there
meeting the right people the right
connections so i didn't want to
affiliate with any of that because it
just
gonna look bad you know what i'm saying
and i i obviously like
you you've seen the whole six nine
[ __ ] you know it's just it's
it's scary man you know you don't want
to affiliate with none of that
and put it into your professional life
you know what i'm saying and it's your
dad though
it's even harder it's weird yeah it's
one of those weird situations but i just
you know i love him and
that's that's his his boys whatever you
know like
they keep in contact sometimes but i i
haven't talked to him in a while so
kind of lost contact with him but i
don't know maybe i hit him up one day
maybe i'll be like hey what's up how you
been
yeah use a p.o box or some [ __ ] you know
not put my address
out there like that because it's not
like it's a threat it's just like
all the guards oh who's he saying what
address yeah
yeah people don't think that it's real
it's very very real
yeah definitely or like or another gang
banger or some other opposite gang
not [ __ ] like oh that's your son oh
that's your son that's right for sure
we know his address i know where he
whatever he stays oh he's making money
oh he's doing good oh yeah oh oh
okay you know somebody broke the whole
thing down yeah
it's like they become obsessed you know
what i'm saying
even though they don't know you they
become obsessed with you
and and once they become obsessed it's a
problem because
then you have random people call you or
you know what i'm saying random
situations random people showing up
randomly at spots and be like what the
[ __ ] you know
it was weird or you'd be walking
somewhere else and be like hey man this
are you this guy
and you're like what the [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] kidding me right now like
like this one situation where um
i was [ __ ] you know when pokemon was
very popular
it's so funny dude this [ __ ] is jumping
pokemon when we were kids or pokemon
came
out again everybody knows yeah pokemon
go everyone's going crazy right
so this one time right we were me and my
friends are leaving sizzlers and
there was like a group of people
catching a rare pokemon outside right
and i was like yo let's go check it out
[ __ ] it you know we're all playing and
[ __ ] in the app
and i crossed the street right and i was
like yo i'm gonna go to a shadow lanes
it's on
vermont and fourth or eighth street or
some [ __ ] like that
and right there is really populated by
another gang like it
obviously 18th street that's the big
whatever the whole point is that that
gang was there and then
it was another gang that pressed me
because they were looking for those guys
and they're like hey are you i wouldn't
think the tattoo guy with the long hair
and video
games yep is the guy we're
so i played pokemon right and i was like
hey
i'm gonna go across the street and catch
this pokemon real quick and
me like an idiot i i walk off from the
whole group that was there
and i go by myself across the street and
then three guys come up to me and
they're like hey man
are you are you boyo boyle's like my
nickname from like high school you know
they used to call me boyle like hey
you know like boyo like i don't know it
was weird like it was a high school
nickname
people still call me that they still
recognize me but i hear hello
call you that yeah you say i go oh yeah
well then when people are like oh you
know ratchet man or whatever they're
like who's
your life yeah yeah so it's like boyo
high school you know
ratchet man after high school and
becoming this
uh wherever the [ __ ] i am you know but
yeah so long story short
i get pressed by these guys and they say
you're boyle and i was like holy [ __ ]
they [ __ ] know me you know so there's
no denying it
like oh who are you man like you know so
i was like
yeah it's me who's who the [ __ ] asking
type [ __ ]
and then they're like hey man yours hood
taxes yours money
and i was like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like who do i owe money to
and if i do owe money how much you know
i was like how much who am i paying this
to right and he's like oh you all the
hood money
and i was like you know what wait a
minute you know i was like hold up let
me make a call real quick
and then i called my dad and i was like
at that time i was
you know talking to my dad back and
forth and everything
so when you call inside it's the main
dude has the cell phone you know and
then i was like hey
put my dad on the phone you know and
they get the message out yeah yeah
they're like they pass either they
pass the phone or whatever he's like
what's going on because i have the phone
right now so it's gonna take a while
he's like some guy outside is saying
that i win taxes in the hood or whatever
i don't do none of that you know like
he's like put that [ __ ] on the
phone dude and i was like
all right here's about to get real so i
was like here you go
dude i gave him the phone i don't know
what the [ __ ] he told him bro he gave me
my phone back he's like hey man
you have some stuff on your on your
shoulder but it was all these like leafs
and flowers because if they were gonna
jump me i put my back towards like the
wall
there was like all these bushes and
leaves so i was thinking like uh
you know like a karate movie like or
what like
back to back back to back you know type
[ __ ] so i was like if they're gonna jump
me
i'm just gonna put my back on the wall
and just fight them like
in front you know like yeah i'm not
gonna let them hit me from the back type
[ __ ] but um
so yeah so long story short they just
wipe me down they're like yo man you got
some stuff on you and they gave me my
phone back
he said oh and he's like he wants to
talk to you and i was like hey what
what happened he's like tell him we're
going to call him and then he was like
all right cool you say yo and i told
them yo they're going to call you
and he was like all right all right for
sure i don't know what he said
all i had to say is like hey man i know
maria
and then he was like you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
i was like hey man you don't know who
you're talking to man like
this is like i don't ever do the stress
call you know or stress signal you know
but this time i was like hey man this is
deep
this is i don't listen turn into
something else yeah i don't
i'm not from this world that's their
[ __ ] fam
my family [ __ ] you know so for everyone
out there man
yeah people that aren't involved it's
just like a movie of like oh god
yeah good ass fools want to kill me you
don't want to shoot people back because
you're going to go to [ __ ] prison and
live with these guys yeah
yeah you don't want to do that so stop
hitting up people that you know aren't
[ __ ] affiliated yeah it makes me so
upset right that's a lady makes me sad
like you can be walking down and people
are like you know you're not
from it's like i don't know if they turn
around like this
obviously something if they don't go
who's the [ __ ] that it's
yeah yeah when they swing on you you'll
know if they're affiliated yeah
yeah like this like another story right
i was uh
my mom put me in karate class this is a
little funny story my mom put me in
karate class
i was probably 10 or some [ __ ] right
here's this mean little chubby kid yeah
trying to you know learn karate
or whatever and i remember walking home
because she couldn't pick me up and i'm
walking home this
other gang right this is welcome to la
another gang passes by
screams done another [ __ ] right
the other gang that was chilling on that
block runs so i'm like oh
something's about to go down and hear me
with my karate suit running away
like a chubby kid but they caught up to
me i gassed out they're like what would
you say and then i'm the first guy to
start beating up
because they thought i said that but i
was running away because i was like
they're about to shoot this place up you
know like so i start running away
they're like [ __ ] you this is not they
start
jumping me dude i go home with a black
guy
and i was like mom never again i'm doing
this karate [ __ ] she's like why i got
beat up i was like over here like oh
yeah i'm trying to fight somebody
he's like come over here fat boy
dude i got beat up dude i got jumped by
some other gang but i
i was like what the [ __ ] you know you
know it's crazy it's like
yeah let's jump that 10 year old in the
karate gear yeah you gotta be a
real loser to do that [ __ ] right yeah it
was one of those man but i learned my
lesson you know like you know growing up
just
head behind the car and waited hey don't
walk through this place don't walk
through that place if you're not gonna
you know what i'm saying
i'll spot gang full game from like a
mile away but yeah
i'm gonna take the long way home yeah
cause it means like
i'm not gonna i'm sorry yeah yeah i'm
gonna get my ass whooped for trying to
stand yes i'm gonna try to
stand up for myself yeah because i'm
gonna get stomped i just don't want to
get whatever
yeah yeah just don't want to get [ __ ]
stabbed bro there's a lot of those in
high school like there's trolley girls
fighting in like
lunch time for sure titties out stabbing
all kinds of shells what the [ __ ] the
stabbings is this thing that pisses me
off the most
yeah yeah weak dude that this fight
before before shootouts like
you know like sorry for all the
columbine people and all that but we
survived that [ __ ] too in another way in
another form you know
after school after school you had all
the gangsters outside yeah
outside ready to shoot everybody next
thing you know
we're over here it's crazy a grown ass
man let's go head outside the high
school and try to catch somebody
yeah grown-ass [ __ ] loser bro you're
a [ __ ]
loser yeah but that's that's part of the
part
and then again it's it's a mentality you
might be 25 i mean mentally is 12.
yeah grew up around a bunch of grown men
that are 12. yeah there's some people
that still think like that bro
it's sad bro that's sad and it's like
it's more of like
yo we could just smoke like a joint
together we'll probably be french you
like that show too i like that show too
yeah yeah you could be a game maker i
just do my weed [ __ ]
see i was always that guy that kept this
so cool with all sides
same yeah with that weed so they yeah so
i was just that musician
that's happy yeah but those times just
explained
yeah but i mean that's that's part of
life man you can't always win everybody
of course i'm the same but look at that
you could be
doing music doing this working with
diamond working with this working with
this and people still hit you
asking where you're from oh yeah yeah
that's that's a long ass hair and rocker
shirts on and they're over here
yeah yeah i mean that's like i said
that's la for you man
that's l.a you don't even have to look
the part you know but yes hey man
that's why i haven't really drove the
monte carlo around i'm waiting for it
like the first where are you from
from northern california no no
look at my blue shoes yeah like what
yo i'm gonna roll around with a red and
a blue hat depending on where the [ __ ] i
am
yo right after uh nipsy hustle got
killed
yeah uh i went to go pick up rosie about
two blocks from where that's acts our
friends are friends with him or whatever
yeah but they own a salon
yeah so rosie's at the salon and i'm
gonna go pick her up and i realized i
was wearing the diamond shirt you gave
me it has the red
letters the baseball jacket and i'm
driving down like south central
mexican kids bumping smoking joints with
all this red sweater
red numbers on i went oh first time in
my life i went
taking my shirt off i rode around with
no
shirt my nope uh done took the whole
[ __ ] thing off in traffic
no hell no yeah south central's not even
it's just different the red
you know brown i'm gonna get a shot at
yeah should not be running
red [ __ ] letters on my channel
crenshaw you know
right after that [ __ ] just happened yeah
no yeah no that's a death wave but yeah
no um
that's what i did i i was just very
cautious i was very cautious around
everybody just like i always kept it
cool you know some people still reach
out from there they're like
they told me hey man if you know if you
ever have some [ __ ]
send it this way we'll handle it for you
but i'm like all right i don't owe you
nothing
yeah i don't wanna know you nothing so
i'll think about it it's not even like
oh i'm better than you it's not that
it's like
no i'm not like you yeah i'm not i'm not
trying to get involved yeah i just don't
want it because once you're there it's
never going away
you stay one favorite turns into
exactly but what about that time like oh
[ __ ] all right you did help me yeah yeah
so yeah no i get it i get it and they're
not doing anything that's not real
yeah it's like yo we helped you you help
us oh you oh so you just take [ __ ] for
free now you owe me money yeah yeah
so all right that's that's pretty much
how i get it
yeah i my dad yeah but that's a whole
different life yeah yeah
so that book was pretty much me back to
the book story
me showing his whole
life from 91 92 93 94 so it was all the
pictures he was saying
just like photos of him sending me also
there's only one photo when he came out
and and they uh
you know the kfc on western
the only kfc on western if you maybe
know only kfc
does that have a huge bucket on the top
yeah well then yes i do actually
right after the freeway yeah yeah that's
right turn left down uh
where shall kingsley kingsley street
yeah yeah the only kfc in the hood right
there
that there's like a dining up there i
guess yeah that
i have a photo of that but like in the
80s and that was
him and my mom meeting for the first
time then while he's out yeah yeah
he's out there's only one photo of that
literally i only have one
he was only out that long literally in
case you get a picture and then go back
type type [ __ ] yeah and then a few of
them and a few photos obviously in our
like
living room kitchen with all his homies
holding guns and
you know just a typical gang [ __ ] you
know like
uh it was that him in prison him how he
started his back
all his ideas the whole back piece a
mural
like my mom and all that [ __ ] like all
the photos
you have one little sister um no i my
sisters came after
he he over from a different day yeah
yeah yeah oh you don't i have a step dad
so i'm the only child
oh yeah yeah so i'm the only child
from him is your dad he is he is
he always staying he's life sentenced
now yeah yeah yeah
yeah so okay so he never getting back no
he's not doing none of that
to the point where like every time he
would call me he'd be like hey what's up
hook me up with
auntie or something fool hooked me up
with like oh later
yeah like pick me up with your girl's
friends or something for tell them to
write to me i'm like bro
oh my gosh yeah like he's he's yeah he's
he's [ __ ]
that sucks yeah i know sad ending bro
yeah but he
he's cool though he went at our age
though yeah he went in our
rh yeah straight up like literally like
1921 or something
like no yeah but that's the life he
chose man like yeah
that's what happens maybe better luck
next time dude your next life
yeah come back and be a saint bro but
yeah he all i mean like i still [ __ ]
with him man regardless you know like
i never liked that joint now oh yeah
awesome i never hated him you know i
never had hold grudges or nothing like
i don't know deep deep inside like if he
was there or around he would be around
you know what i'm saying like he
wouldn't let me down because i'm his
only
[ __ ] child you know what i'm saying
and he always tries to keep in contact
hit me up on my birthdays or he'll send
me a little bit of my birthday
yeah yeah yeah but he hasn't had my
address because i haven't
hit him up you know like now that i've
moved up you know like
yeah cause it it's crazy man it's a long
story
you told me what happened yeah well
we'll say it on here but yeah for sure
yeah but
i mean that's that's the way it is dude
that's what it has to be um so the book
what's called one more time
los malos that's the name i have the
book
yeah that's the name of his uh click
from the gang oh my god you [ __ ]
named it that bro well it also means the
bad ones
gotcha in spanish so i didn't name it
because of his clique
it just it makes perfect it makes
perfect sense
you get what i'm saying the bad ones and
then that's his name of his clique so
people put two and two together it's
like oh he's from florence
oh okay you know like you know it makes
sense you know
got you and culture shit's so deep it's
crazy yeah and uh it sold really well i
sold out at the la book fair
i sold out from prince too like i should
before the shop even
like i tried but i just you know what i
want to just keep that
exclusive and not you know like if you
got it you got it if you know about it
you know about it you know
so like now that we're talking about it
most people are probably going to be
interested
but it's one of those like i'd rather
just keep it there and like if you got
it you got it you know that's cool one
of those
yeah yeah there's no need to re-blast
that
yeah i got you you know okay cool cool
so
that brings us up to what middle school
yeah middle school
when did you start getting into skating
oh skating
middle school well i was always into
skating because of ninja turtles
if really that was a guy i was simpsons
yeah that's why me was ninja turtles
ninja turtles got me into skateboarding
so then my mom
bought me the ninja turtle skateboard
with the big like
you know that big plastic like those old
tony hawk ones you know straight to the
side
well yeah the bars it has the bars but
it had also like a
like uh oh the lump on the back yes i
remember
that oh [ __ ] huge yeah and then the big
huge green wheel
so yeah i had one of those and um
that's how i started skating right and
um
i started uh pushing by myself holding
on to the gate and trying to like ollie
and do all of that and then i used to
always skate with the guys on the block
and then i had like our armenian friend
of mine robert
lived across the street so we used to
just always skate we used to call
we skate down the block at our local
church
and we used to call it the red zone and
we had the code for the church and we
used to open it and just all these
little four stairs that it was
that's sick or do little stuff like that
you know try to
like go through the whole church because
it was an empty lot you know
just manual all the onto little curves
stuff like that you know i'm sick
but middle school i would say
i start really like skating skating and
the reason i'm asking is because you're
so deep in with all these skaters but
that's mainly from a diamond standpoint
no no no
because you know how much i mean every
[ __ ] pro skater i named it oh no
they're full i'm like
how and why it started in high school
i'm gonna say uh all the pro skaters
uh when i when we were in high school
everyone was coming up at that time
chad muska was coming up um
eric ellington uh andrew reynolds
um and they were all like in hollywood
just skating you know
like there were so many people just like
in the rise you know like mike rosa
aaron yeager
josh dad i could start naming a bunch of
people right
and i remember my local skate shop
it's called uh it used to be around the
corner i used to go scale the time and
like watch
videos and meet pros here and there that
used to go to the local shop right yeah
and um the the the skate shop used to
call instrument skate sounds
and they used to like do hip-hop stuff
break dancy stuff skating
tagging you know just like the all
elements of hip-hop
type [ __ ] you know because of uh one of
my friends called
tim he has a brand now called art form
you know because that's he's been
always into like all of those elements
and
he introduced me to a lot of people like
aaron yeager
mike rosa and they all live like on like
let's say bronson or whatever like
buyer middle school so growing up we
used to see them like oh [ __ ]
they live right there you know yeah so
we like yo we should just go knock and
see if we can buy some stuff
you know so we so we were one of those
kids we're like
nah man next time you see him ask him if
he'll sell you like some trucks or
something or use skateboard or whatever
sometimes they used to be like yo here
you you bought this just take all of
this
hook you up with a bunch of shirts at
that time uh
dna skateboards rogue status
uh alien workshop um
glove shoes were coming up uh
so just you know danny gonzalez i
remember danny gonzalez on the block
just like you know like that's how you
got you got lucky where you moved huh
literally like east hollywood was
hollywood was the place you know what
i'm saying like
we used to go buy skateboards from from
eliza steamer
she was coming up you know like so many
skaters bro like we just just go
and to the point where they were so cool
they were like
yes now yeah you were the little homies
that would come and buy all the [ __ ]
and tell other people like yo the homie
[ __ ] hook you up if you buy something
from him he'll hook you up
but i would do that because he'll hook
me the [ __ ] up too if i bring more
people you know yeah
so the point where we'll knock him oh
josh is showering right now
and his girl opened the door she's like
just wait right here you know so me and
my friends in high school always had all
the connections like
through all the circle that i grew up
with like all the homies in hollywood
hollywood natives i would say um we had
all the skateboard plugs
and that's how we uh that's how we met
bobby lee
oh yeah that was actually one of my
other notes mm-hmm that's
that's how we met bob brandley started
hanging out with bobby lee on mad tv for
what [ __ ] reason
well hold on first off i believe's a
grown-ass man
it's like hey little young kids do you
want to skate and then you know i'll
film it
and then you come and do free extra work
for me on that tv
well it wasn't like that it was more
like
we met bobby lee and it was like like i
said
the group of friends that i was hanging
out with that we still hang out uh
hollywood native kids uh we all
[ __ ] knew all the pro skaters so
we're like yo bobby lee wants to buy
some gear
or whatever he wants to buy skate stuff
so we were like
[ __ ] it let's go see if we can get my tv
tickets
and sell it to him you know and he would
be like yo pull up to the set
i'll buy it off you guys or whatever so
we we would go
me and the homies will show up and we
would just get tickets we will watch
some shows
i even came out in one like a grand
theft auto one you know it was crazy
of mad tv yeah yeah yeah it was it's
pretty old i've been trying to look for
it on youtube but
i don't know i don't think youtube
existed at the time what a random
random connection yeah it was it was
super random so
we used to just sell skateboard products
to him because he wanted to skate and
that's how we got tickets we saw a lot
of bands we came out in a
tv show like it was just random
random yeah we met everybody will's
tassel daryl wilson [ __ ] out of here
yeah i was just a kid
like actually one of my friends actually
the guy robert
that uh he uh he's skate
with us all the time he's like our only
armenian friend growing up at the time
you know
i think he has one of either uh
deborah wilson's or somebody like a
whole mad tv actual like
uh skit like you know the pamphlet they
give you when they make the
script script yeah that's the word i was
looking for script he has a
sign and everything yeah i watch man tv
so heavy bro yeah i mean so every
saturday
every day i used to i used to always bug
my mom with that no
oh from stuart i don't want to say dude
i love like a michael mcdonald
no you know look what why so you met
bobby lee because you were skating you
look at you kids like can i buy some
[ __ ]
oh you guys like mad tv here's some
tickets it was i think how
cool it was just random bro it was just
one of those random things he saw us
probably with a bunch of [ __ ] gear
leaving some spot he was like what the
[ __ ] were these
what the these kids you know it was like
hey man i'll buy some of that [ __ ]
yeah it was yeah it was random and
i that was that's actually really random
and we saw tony hawk too when we were
kids
uh yeah through man no not through him
but just through my tv
you know like they were filming it when
he was there no he if tony hawk was
there yeah
it wasn't bobby lee wasn't there tony
hawk was filming and our
our middle school is like literally next
door to like
channel five channel fox 11 so
we were they were like all the like
studios where they do judge judy
malibu ca all these like little you know
little shows that they have right but i
was like mad tv what the [ __ ]
filming next door like that's sick and
then we all were like seeing
i think bucky lastic was there too like
they were all skating the rap and i was
like what the [ __ ]
you know but it was a mate it was a it
was a tony hawk
we're like is that we're just like who
is that you know like who the hell
skating that
and boom tony hawk kids were like
holy [ __ ] like literally the episode you
could see all the kids from the
like all the homies from the block
remember that [ __ ] like you remember
tony hawk dude what the [ __ ] and yeah we
were kids imagine
going to middle school and they're like
hey you can't go to
class today to this side because they're
recording even stevens on the next side
oh nice you get what i'm saying i always
wondered that when i passed by
schools in illegal yeah i wonder what
[ __ ] these kids see man yeah it must be
badass
yeah it will it would be like that like
hey you guys can't go in the hallways at
this time
because we're recording even stevens or
[ __ ] like that you know
that's sick as [ __ ] so it was like
you grow up yeah so you kind of like you
know you're opening that yeah
yeah and it's up to you to make
something out of it in hollywood
you know like with your connections or
whatever you know how awesome
what would it have been to grow up like
oh it's their filming even stevens oh
sit here longer cool yeah i was just so
into
filming [ __ ] as a kid yeah but see i
don't think we had that mentality
and me personally i was on something i
wasn't merced just a little talented
yeah i wanted to do that
so bad i i probably would have thought
you know like i've
like people let's say in iowa they're
like [ __ ]
i wish i was in hollywood dude i want to
be an actor or some [ __ ]
and we literally have it in front of our
feet and we are like
sometimes clueless as a child you know
yeah and now that i've
grown up i'm like [ __ ] if i would have
known all this [ __ ] that i know
now back then [ __ ] i would have been
that little
rich famous celebrity you know
whatever yeah bro i used to serve coffee
because i used to work at starbucks
to the [ __ ] what's his name from the
sandlot uh the
the great bambito what's that about the
rehearsal kid yeah yeah
so i used to serve coffee to him all the
time used to see him all the time
so he has a kid [ __ ] normal so
the first like celebrity i ever met i
was in the doc martin store in san
francisco and i met sarah gilbert
darling yeah from roseanne
yeah but back as a kid i was so
and you know that i'm so into movies so
yeah
seeing these people like so you know
when you said this line of this live
that was me that was that was that kid
so for me and when i started filming
[ __ ] i go oh so that's how you did it so
now it's like fascinating to watch
people direct stuff yeah yeah
i love it i love it yeah i was the
opposite
i didn't care there were militia winners
out of high school you know
like our high school hollywood high was
known to be like
actors came here uh famous musicians
photographers
writers etc you know i was watching
hollywood squares all day and [ __ ] as a
little kid
like i loved that so me personally i
didn't care i didn't really
you're [ __ ] done with it i was
overexposed at that point yeah
yeah and like also i hated going to
school imagine going to school
and like it's in the middle of a tourist
spot
literally in the tourist heaven you know
and you have to like
bump your way through it go yeah like
ugh
gotta go to school i get it and it was
just one of those like
man this sucks like this oh you're
filming your first movie good job
i have math class right now every time
i'm doing something really fun i think
man there's times this time eight years
ago or something i was doing something
boring
i think about you like that all the time
so think about it when you're having fun
yeah there's a kid across the street in
class right now hating life
yeah yeah but we all have to go through
it of course we'll have to go through
that time in our lives definitely
and uh there was actually another movie
that they uh
filmed in while you were at school yeah
it was crazy to me
wild wild something all things i think
with matt dillon no no no no no no
it's ah [ __ ] i can't remember this movie
it's about these girls it's about this
girl
you thanks that really narrowed it down
she had hair and legs i don't know it
was uh
nicole kidman though nicole kidman i
don't know
i don't know wild things movies i don't
know but it was it was it was pretty
sick because
we just heard there was a big like pool
lesbian seat
wild things bro it's wow that's denise
richards that's
that chick from uh black hair chick from
okay from the christmas oh well then
yeah there you go yeah it's
it's a it's a the guy that check out my
teeth
yeah from uh something about mary oh
okay okay remember the guy
who was that private detective it's matt
dillon yeah it's mad dylan
yeah matt dillon never campbell kevin
bacon yeah and denise richards damn they
didn't put denise richard's name
on the cover but they put kevin bacon
and he's not even a main character yo so
there's this liquor store
actually uh trip out this is how crazy
it is this i
i'm telling you growing up i didn't care
i saw met paul walker they filmed it
in the corner of my liquor store
that literally like around the corner
they're like hey we're gonna record fast
and the furious and
in my head i was like oh [ __ ] they're
locking the street again you know
that's all i just knock on our door
because they film right here yeah so
then they put a little thing
in your door like hey we're filming
filming this time to this
park in your own parking your own part
yeah exactly yeah they tell me like
[ __ ] that you need to move your car
another picture in other words you know
yeah um so yeah i saw paul walker
and they were recording the fast and
furiousness right around the corner of
my house
and another liquor store right in the
corner
they recorded the craft how random yeah
like literally
like around the corner that's why you
were reminding me like of the liquor
stores from my house like from my block
around the block
if you see me as a kid like i'm in a
small farm town that's that's just fun
so i was the kid that i was i would make
an excuse
i'm gonna go to the store just like go
see you know what i'm saying
i'll be like i'll be back i'm gonna go
to the store but i was just over there
like looking
man can i get this juice yeah like yeah
yeah
one of those kids funny yeah but um so
growing up i saw all of that [ __ ] you
know so i was kind of exposed to
whatever
the kid in the world wanted yeah and i
didn't really care
and i should have yeah but then again
you didn't really care because it wasn't
a big deal to you means that's not what
you want
of course yeah but i should have i
should have
like other people wish you know they had
that opportunity and
i think i should have like you know at
least had fun with it but i think i've
i've did it in my own way you know of
course and we're going to get to that
you'll get to that point yeah a whole
different route of 100
dude um so that brings me to another
topic
how and this is how i met you yeah uh
you guys ready this is how i met omar
actually last week remember when i said
when you said oh i took a i took a car
and somebody else rented it i said oh i
have another story about that but i'm
not going to get into it right now
remember marty
this is how i met omar that story is how
i met him
so i knew this guy won't say his name i
knew this guy we both mutually knew
my friend jebus rented a car for me guys
he rented a car for me and i'm
the lady's like do you want insurance
[ __ ]
dollars a day [ __ ] you in my head i went
no thank you ma'am
because you know back then i wasn't
making any money like 16 a day
so much more when it's already costing
me money [ __ ] you
so i didn't get the insurance always get
the [ __ ] insurance
all right the first time i ever met one
my friend one who makes medicaid hot
wings medicated uh lemonade guys
i went to a place called the head well i
won't say it
it's a place where they film pineapple
express where he gets hit in the alley
with the slurpees yeah with their
smoking weed that is an actual
underground weed bar so i was there
and they're showing me like oh they film
pineapples wait oh yeah
there's a spot so anyway first i was
high as [ __ ] super fun met one of my
best friends that i would meet
one later on yeah i'm leaving i go to
turn on the freeway and somebody [ __ ]
hits me on the side scrapes the whole
car up
ah wasn't even my fault
so our mutual friend i go to him the
next i was gonna go smoke weed with him
so i go with him and i'm like i'm
stressed the [ __ ] out i can there's no
way i could pay for this show i was
broke as [ __ ]
there's no way i could pay for this it's
not my name i'm in [ __ ] another
part of the state jesus is up i'm like
stressed
stressed stressed the [ __ ] out and i'm
like yo
what can i do how can i get this done so
he took me to a car guy
he told me what to do and he even helped
me but
he at least they were trying yeah they
could have been like
[ __ ] you go return it yeah he gave me
the steps to anyway
while i'm sitting there stressed the
[ __ ] out about this car
at our mutual friend's house this full
walks in
he walks in to drop off diamond a bunch
of diamond stuff diamond clothing
to our homie and i he meets we
introduced me to you
and then i think we chilled one time and
then we just been chilling ever since
yeah
that was like seven years ago it was
just one of those things where
uh when i think when we were meeting or
when we met up for the first time
or whatever we [ __ ] we knew all the
stupid the
most randomest songs oh yeah and they
were sure
and then rosie was like oh my god
there's two of you you [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah and it was like
after that i was like yeah man i could
say dumb movie
[ __ ] phrase and you'll know yeah like
or you can finish very rare you know
it's very and it's hard to find someone
almost like
weird like you you know like i
i can sing a song and then next to you
know thomas would be like ah
damn it no stuck in my head yeah i would
be like if it makes you
happy why are you gonna start you're
gonna start on the show [ __ ]
you'll be here in like 10 minutes yeah
it's really in my head yeah
that's what justin was here for a week
it's the same thing with justin you know
it's like oh
no it's just not gonna stop yeah
but that's how i met omar
and um you were working at diamond how
did
that venture start uh the doctor
this is a big grip you're ready clip
ready go how did you start
the diamond part well this is how i got
in diamond the diamond phase of your
life so
the diamond face um the diamond face
this is how i got in there so i have a
friend
and uh i have a bunch of friends
obviously but in the
skate world the guys that really gave me
an opportunity to get in there
was my friend uh junior and grayson
grayson
uh it's like he'd been working at podium
that's like a big like i've heard of
that that's where like
geron used to work and uh most of the
like
uh i would say designers from like dbs
and like
um i like maddox and like stuff like
that you know
i think uh girl and chocolate and
so he used to work for the warehouse
packing boxes and all that
and one of our friend uh tucker uh
he got in diamond he was going to be
like the head designer and shoe designer
and all that stuff
so then um a diamond was growing
rapidly like super crazy bro to the
point where i didn't even know
what kind of monster it was at the time
you know what i'm saying
and so i was like i wouldn't rock that
[ __ ] you know at first you know i was
like
that's not my style you know but like
because i was all like
rocker when i met you you were wearing
like all black sabbath shirts and [ __ ]
yeah like
rocker fool you know i was just wearing
all metal [ __ ] you know just
long hair hat or [ __ ] whatever you
know just metal [ __ ]
metal shirts whatever but um
[Music]
in other words rocker food yeah i got a
rock
but um yeah [ __ ] i got into diamond
and like
uh my friend grayson went uh tucker
the main dude the guy told grayson like
hey come check out diamond
and they needed interns like they wanted
interns at that time that's how you
started so i started as an
intern i started as an intern
and uh they were like do this thing
where you had to work like
six months bro to get put on type [ __ ]
you know
like on payroll but they would hook you
the [ __ ] up with like all the gear and
it was expensive so
it would kind of balance because your
result yeah or you just sell it
like as normal whatever but that was
like before when like
they didn't have a system it think about
it it's a
big ass [ __ ] worldwide company owned
by
one guy skater own or whatever him and
at the time oh i don't know geron
and everybody uh so it's this big
monster right
and that [ __ ] monster uh
it was [ __ ] a bunch of high-ass fools
running the warehouse skater fools you
know what i'm saying
so we were all interns at first you know
and from interns uh we ended up getting
into like payroll
and that's how i was starting like
packing boxes
packing orders make sure like when the
ups truck came
like you know make sure all the boxes
get in there
yeah warehouse stuff you know everyone
was running around
and then like somehow i uh
i ended up um running the shoe
department
for a while because my friend junior
that got me in there
he's like hey man uh i'm gonna go work
at quiet life
junior oh man i quiet life same day
quiet life episode yeah
so junior that set up your board at the
quiet life of bazooka yo
um i think i might go to quiet life and
you know like run
run the whole online thing and for all
of them because
quiet life is it's really small but like
they're
they're out there you know what i'm
saying so one person could really
like the same way as you you could
really run it by yourself you know what
i'm saying but
sometimes you do need help you know i'm
pretty sure you're starting to notice
that
but um so junior got me in there he's
like yo take my spot
and you know they're gonna put you on
payroll and then you become the
footwear manager and you'll handle that
and i'm gonna go to quiet life and run
that
i was like all right cool you know like
[ __ ] yeah gave me your job
thank you brother thank you [ __ ] yeah
you know and then little by little i
started
um you know just helping out a lot with
the like the shoe wear
and all that but i met uh my friend
angel
miramontes angel uh he did all the
marketing stuff
he did all the cool stuff but me and him
were so cool
because we related through music and
like jokes and
all that [ __ ] you know so we used to
listen to the same
music like i used to like like trap but
like the dumb
trap like literally migos was like brand
new like they were just
had to their first hit was like trapping
not the house with the boy is that the
bando some like
old [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
but it was dope as [ __ ] for us
we're like yes or [ __ ] that's just gonna
come up atlanta scene right
and i'm gonna get to that after but like
so he was doing all the cool stuff you
know meeting up with like
mac miller will come he would give him
clothes and
he probably met justin before yeah yeah
so he uh let's say
uh wiz khalifa would come then he would
come they were all doing artists
relationships yeah he would
they would all come to angel to my
friend angel because of another guy
that worked at def jam named brocky
marciano
so brocky is like he was the main
marketing guy he was like the def jam
and r he's also shot out i think
kendrick gave him a shout out at the
last [ __ ] album too
like he's he's the man brocky is the man
you know
um so when i started seeing that i was
like dude
i [ __ ] that's this that's what i want to
do you know
now in the company i was like [ __ ] i
want to get in the marketing scene like
they're going to trade shows they're
going training
that makes the brand fun yeah they're
traveling you know they're going
to europe they're going here vegas doing
new york
san francisco florida i was like damn
that's what i want to do you know like i
know i can make this brand like
dope you know and i can help my friend
you know like i could help nick in
another way you know so
um i started seeing that that he was
doing that with those type of artists
right like the action bronson's
the uh alchemists you know like
that's how i met prodigy when he came
one but i was doing marketing at the
time already so
that's i was dope you know like rest in
peace
uh but um so started seeing that i was
like i want to do that
you know so i little by little i started
like helping
angel like yo how can i help you man
like you know i'm trying to get in there
and like
uh like literally from packing boxes to
marketing you know
but at the time i was also meeting some
people that were gonna become
the biggest artists in the world you
know what i'm saying because i know you
told me about a rapper named 217 that's
coming out he's going to be big
yeah that's a crazy ass name i remember
when you told me that [ __ ] yeah
so so at that time i was into
the trap scene it was new amigos were
just coming out
bankroll fresh like all these people bro
fat man key
sonny digital mcconan like
it was like all first like
everything first like um who else
travis porter like
all this like atlanta artists right
at that time they were coming up young
thug you know just like [ __ ] like that
so when i when i was getting into the
scene and all that
uh ham on everything and lay was popping
like ham on everything is like
underground parties in l.a
like like it's a great literally like
underground warehouse parties where you
can go to the bathroom and guess what
the bathroom don't have nothing it's
just a girl in a guy booth like
not even like it's not even split
nothing like it's just
going boom boom like it's a whole room
that people are like pulling out big
bags of cocaine
pills xanax weed everything
literally like a trap house environment
insanely awesome underground
[ __ ] ham on everything party bro
it would go crazy all the [ __ ]
artists that
you know blew the [ __ ] up perform the
ham on everything too
like i have footage of like post malone
performing his first show i ham on
everything
uh og macko maxwell green
even waka flocka performed that [ __ ] one
time lit that [ __ ] up
and it's so hot and like musty warehouse
type of vive you know like
almost like where you're like oh [ __ ]
they're gonna shoot this [ __ ] up or
someone's gonna get killed today you
know like
type of vibes you know but also you have
to hold your two and go in the hood
[ __ ] it you know like so i loved going
to hem on everything parties
and i was like yo fat man key fan man
key was like my favorite artist at the
time you know
and became a really good homie of mine
you know
but he was new like most people in la
they were not in
to tune into the atlanta scene you know
and that was
what 2013-14 yeah 2013-14
and i was so at that time i somehow
i was doing i was still doing i was
starting to do the marketing
for diamond they're like yo let's give
him a shot he's already helping us
out you know let's see who can he get
and my head they gave me the artist
relations
yeah the the title title yeah so i was
like i'll say all right that's how you
got into this i didn't know this this is
how i'm gonna i'm gonna
put in some work now i'm gonna go to the
underground [ __ ] parties in la
that these guys are probably not down to
go to you know
i would go to them and i became friends
with the promoter
adam you know and he was cool with me
and everything so i would just
pull up he would they were just like
yeah they'll kill me at the door like i
got you bro
so then i bumped into key
and then i saw him he was about to get a
drink and i was gonna go in there
get a drink too and i bump into him i
was like yo bro i [ __ ] with you
i work for dimes diamond supply code
he's like for diamond i was like yeah
diamond escape brand diamond supply co
he's like yeah [ __ ] with y'all i was
like what's up let me lace you up
he's like oh he's like for sure i'm
gonna be in la for a couple days
what's up pull up to the studio tomorrow
or whatever and i was like all right
cool i'm down what size are you give me
your size and all that [ __ ]
i got you bro i ain't even i ain't in
front of you like and then
boom it's like i popped out they made me
little cards too you know
and they had the diamond logo and
everything so i was like here bro here's
my card you know like it's my email
and then my email was boyo
diamondsupplycode.com
that was facial yes i was official you
know so i was like [ __ ] yeah you know
that's what you're best at yeah just
meeting people just meeting people yeah
just talking yeah just being me and
[ __ ]
vibing with somebody to the point where
he met my mommy
like he ate [ __ ] lunch at my house he
done all that [ __ ] you know my step he
met all my stepdad my family
like came to my house like mad man
savage came to my block like
all these dudes came to my block like
that was love they would be like hey
what's up
like straight from atlanta you know 21
savage you know like
pick me up i got in a sprinter with them
when they were out here you know like
type [ __ ] like it was one of those that
and it's like yo
when you're an artist and you got to be
the relations guy like all right full
and they're like wait this was
no let's chill with him yeah yeah that's
your artist that's your guy from diamond
like
yeah that's the guy it's even it's more
fun
yeah i'll come to atlanta i gotta
connect i got weed i got clothes i know
where to go
and yeah they call you uh so they used
to they fun that's what they're like yo
ratchet man you know because at that
ratchet man came
from my boy keville beats kevill from
south central he makes beats
and at that time he was killing it bro
killing it at tick tock
to the point that par 106 played his
[ __ ]
what is killing it okay so no no i mean
not tick tock i'm sorry it was vine
vine oh okay so he was he was killing it
at vines right
he was the one that made the uh he
recorded some girl
and he was like what it is a what's up
got joke
in the cut god damn so that was him he
made that popular right
and it was playing on the radio so his
vine was going crazy you know
and now at that time i was djing like
all ratchet music i would make the girls
twerk in like
in the parties type [ __ ] you know and
he's like yo i'm gonna call you ratchet
man
that's you're the ratchet man that's
where kevill came up with it
i was like that's hard and then i made a
little dj tag he's like
god damn retro man you got all the
ratchets
that's the tag right that was the tag
for like the dj to drop you know td
whatever and yeah man that's i kept
ratchet man so
when i went to atlanta and people the
the artists that i would meet they're
like yo what's your name bro
i just like ratchet man they're like
what scratch man
oh that's hard you know like what's up
so that everybody will be like yo that's
ratchet you know that's where
just stuck it just stuck so from there
like i was like damn ratchet man
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] with that and then i made
a logo
and which is like the kram style
lettering yeah
yeah and uh [ __ ] that's how i got
this little r
too the same style you know like and
yeah i kept the
ratchet man and then back to the story i
met fat man key
went to the studio the next day and then
he was working with
first fki yeah yeah
but that's the first time i met first
too oh no [ __ ] yeah i met first the
first time i met first
right so first was working on a project
called
fki because his name is fki
right but key fat man key so together it
was fki
you know what i'm saying and
they were working on that project
together so when i met them i went to go
to that studio
and then i [ __ ] dropped off some
clothes to key
and i felt kind of bad because i was
like [ __ ]
first is here like i i like i felt bad
because i didn't bring him nothing type
[ __ ]
but i had some like xl like
like a dark trench coat but he was he
always likes
all black you know and he's really tall
so i was like here man i only have this
right now but i can
give me your link you know like and i'll
hook you up you know i'll send you some
more [ __ ]
or we can link up and then um uh
he was like all right for sure we that's
how i met first
and yeah then after that we just kept it
close
and we used to be like yo we're going to
go to this event
like yg is going to perform this event
he's like you want to come
let's go it's an adidas event and back
then bro
uh at that time you couldn't just send
your email
rsvp plus two and if you make it on time
you get in for free
you know what i'm saying it was open bar
red bull
sponsoring with adidas it was like well
it's the biggest
streetwear brand on the planet for a few
years and you are the artist relations
manager
for all the artists that are about to be
superstars
all right so here here here comes this
crazy fun job yeah so here comes this
crazy story so then
first and key we're like yo let's go to
this adidas thing
and he's like i'm i'm i'm about to go to
the adidas in downtown
yg's gonna perform um link let's link
i was all right so we link up and we try
to go to the door
i was like yo bros i'm with uh fat man
key from atlanta you know
me trying to play the manager role
trying to like get in there you know
without waiting the line i was like this
is fki
first and boom there's this young guy
white guy two braids
wearing a a shooter
not even like a quarterback sleeve
quarterback sleeve
wearing a headband
with a gatorade bottle the gatorade from
like
like about to play football with a
cowboys jersey
and it was possible yeah no tattoos no
nothing
little little like what's up guys you
know those posts and i was like
i met him and guess what we couldn't get
into this [ __ ] event dude
to this event i was like i was like look
man at least let them
in you know like i don't want to go and
[ __ ] it if they if they go in they go in
you know
they were like nah we didn't even get in
bro we didn't get into this [ __ ]
event right we ended up taking an uber
back
and first had a studio and he uh
only first been having studios first had
a studio and first was like yo let's
just go back to the studio
[ __ ] it so we all got a [ __ ]
uber and we went to the [ __ ] um
to the studio and then that's how i met
post malone
and uh he was first was telling me like
yo
like yeah i've been working with him
he's about to be big bro
trust me you know and i knew because i
i always had faith and trust and first
you know anything
first puts his mind through he's gonna
do it and you know like he's like
he he calls his little room the wakanda
like you have to be
like really careful what you say in
there because it like
he wants to manifest it like so he's
like
like if anybody brings anything energy
like bad energy or says something wrong
be like hey bro don't say that around
here
like come on man you know like think
positive yeah yeah
so he calls his little spot wakanda like
he's like bro anything i say he's like
i can't say it out loud because it's
just gonna happen you know so he's just
i like that like he taught me that like
always you know like
just manifest that [ __ ] you know yeah it
was a long time ago but i went to sell
these for some weed one time
because i met him there and i remember
walking in
selling this fool some weed and i look
over this is full playing piano
oh my gosh it sounds hard yeah and then
he turns like oh [ __ ] that's mcconan
and i love mcconan yeah yeah
so i'm gonna keep it a buck it's just
funny to me like
this is how you guys make this music huh
yeah yeah all just chilling smoking
all right you ready all right go all
right everybody shut the [ __ ] up yeah
it's it's great it's good that's why the
music is good because it's just
it's a the environment yeah and i'm
gonna keep it a buck key
was the key to atlanta for me because
he's the one that introduced me to sunny
digital
he introduced me to mcconan he
introduced me to first
like he introduced me to 21 savage
he introduced me to madman savage and
the list goes on you know like
and then it just trickled down from
there you know to the point where
i took a flight to atlanta by myself
it's like
i know you told me the story me saving
my money type [ __ ] you know
like i was like [ __ ] all right they're
gonna have a
uh it was like uh [ __ ]
fools gold or something like that uh
what's his name a track or something uh
yeah a track dj
um so it was atlanta artists was gonna
perform
and then that day i met uh playboy cardi
little uzi rich the kid uh
[Music]
i think uh the whole like father life
[ __ ]
yeah the new kids but bro i have footage
where people
didn't know uzi like they didn't know
who uzi was bro i have footage like
and but uzi was killing the [ __ ] and
people were just like
who is this new artist you know and then
you always tell me about these new
artists that go i don't know those names
yeah i mean you told me you told me
about lil uzi vert
made in tokyo too made in tokyo and 21
savage
post malone i found out to germcilla
yeah because he played me a thing i go
who is this this is funny awesome yeah
and that was that first
song he ever damn it this was yeah blow
the [ __ ] up why did i ever send it
dude i said yeah i knew it second i
heard it all this is it
this is gonna blow up we were uh so
we were at uh rex studio rex is uh he
had like
he has a studio and palisades is like
his house you know
and that's where like a lot of like dope
ass hits got
you know put on to the album and stuff
for for posts and [ __ ]
and i think it was like the second day
or third day
and post was bro i think he was couch
surfing too
like right there i believe yeah at that
at that time you know i
don't i don't remember too much like
detail of like him
sleeping wise but he was always there at
that studio recording and [ __ ] in that
room
so we would go there and i would i would
i would kick it with wrecks and smoke
with [ __ ] wrecks i would bring all
this weed and [ __ ]
cause um i don't even know where the
[ __ ] i was getting my weed from but i
was getting a lot of weed at that time
and i was just like [ __ ] i'm gonna go
smoke over there bye vow with them you
know
just vibe and [ __ ] and yeah bro the
third day he's like [ __ ]
with khalifa reposted it and uh i forgot
who else mac reached out
and then boom it's just like it just
started blowing the [ __ ] up bro
and i saw him she had to see the whole
thing happen yeah i saw him
smoking he was like holy [ __ ] dude
what the [ __ ] you know and then i saw
their
video and then he got signed a republic
and i saw it all
trickled like and then like my homie
schmidty
shout out to smitty he [ __ ] dj's for
a post now
like oh that's a skinny dude right yeah
yeah when i met
you yeah yeah schmidty yeah so schmidty
and he's also on like twitch and then it
does all that like
grand theft auto [ __ ] you know role play
or whatever but um
yeah like schmidty's still there like
djing for post now and like
it's just like it's crazy like you know
we didn't know what was going to happen
he's the first to produce postmodern
[ __ ]
uh yeah yeah he he did uh most of his
stuff yeah
uh he yeah yeah he did it yeah uh
yeah for sure the first time i walked in
there
no no not the first time but it does way
after i just saw all the [ __ ] post
malone plaques go what the [ __ ]
yeah first remember i didn't know where
i was at i was just going i was going
there
oh no no i did genius man what was it
after
one of the times because i told you guys
we'd way years before that
yeah i love i don't know i've been
trying to get you to play him madden
so we wanted to do this thing before
kovid and i was gonna do this thing
where i
bet weed all right i come up with a qp
put the qp on the table and go all right
rapper
it's called thomas plays rappers in
madden
but i was going to bet a qp and all
right whoever wins gets to take this
[ __ ] home
i hope i get to take it home because
he's really good at madden
i'm really good at man too but i don't
play yeah i don't [ __ ] play but i
am pretty [ __ ] good at men yeah so i
need to go to the studio we'll vlog it
it'll be just a day and literally in my
notebook
play rappers and what i wrote down like
my idea sketch
and then i was gonna get the title but
yeah but first yeah
first this is genius he uh did like two
chains
travis porter iggy salia a bunch of
cash out like he's been in the game for
a cool minute and he's doing a lot of
good [ __ ] yeah hell yeah
that's awesome um we won't get into the
music part of
your life yet yeah because i want to
bring that full circle yeah so you went
to the artist solutions doing all that
you got so deep one of my things was how
did you get so deep into skateboarding
but that was before diamond
yeah yeah so your life was pretty
destined to hang out with these
[ __ ] and skate and all this
[ __ ] anyway
yeah yeah yeah yeah cause if you guys
watching it all connects though because
the the rappers dudes some of them
they're like oh we skate too and then
they would
like everything well weed music and
skateboarding go hand in hand
yeah yeah if you you have to [ __ ] with
all three remember
instruments gay sounds taught me that
all the elements of hip hip-hop is was
rap
break dancing tagging [ __ ]
smoking weed and making music
literally it was all that was like i
guess what it literally
is a thing actually like the elements of
hip-hop or some [ __ ]
yes like ingredients right am i right
that's the first time marty's talked to
them
i just thought of it he just said yeah
that's ingredients yeah yeah
i should have nailed it yeah you guys
don't even know we just did our first
little
live stream just gave the fans a little
taste and [ __ ] we just did right now oh
nice
on what ig did you oh
the man's going sorry a little bit of
water and we'll get on to this next part
but
the next part fans are going to be
really excited about but yeah man that's
that's
it was all meant to be i guess
you know came full circle dude
definitely
so skating was first that was one of my
next things skating
was in high school you chill with all
these people hanging out doing your
thing bobby lee [ __ ]
then you go show working at diamond
diamond packing boxes working hard and
then you get to do artist relations
and that's why you know all these
[ __ ] major artists like
like we do yeah you're friends yeah yeah
so
so that's how that worked you became
artist relations and it was the biggest
brand of the planet
yeah and the biggest brand on the planet
has a really really really fun artist
relations guy
yeah you know what i mean so it's it's
it can't not work
yeah so my next thing is
thank you guys again so much for
watching the dope as usual podcast this
ad sponsor is brought to you by
manscaped so from all our fans from all
around the world us
canada australia south africa europe
wherever you're at
thank you guys so much for supporting so
big announcement coming from manscape
guys they are now 100
worldwide so you have the choice of
getting the lawnmower 4.0 by itself or
you can get the whole 4.0 package
and that's now available around the
world it's now in australia
singapore south africa uk canada a bunch
of other countries guys it's now
worldwide if you want to buy anything go
ahead and go to www.manscape.com forward
slash yola or if you forget that just go
to manscape.com
use the code yola in checkout that's 20
off plus free shipping so let's hop into
the performance package 4.0 the new
lawnmower 4.0 has a ceramic blade it's
to
minimize cutting your dick open so it
comes with this travel bag if
if you're a dude and you were born after
1940 you probably have one of these bags
so as you know it's about to get real
goofy and funny and hilarious so
this is ball deodorant croppers over
ball deodorant yes guys
manscape's got your balls smelling
better and then right here is the actual
machine that lawnmower 4.0 this is skin
safe wireless charger waterproof it has
a light on it
it basically you have no [ __ ] excuse
to be nasty so as i said before if
you're interested at all go to
manscape.com forward slash yola or just
go to manscape.com and in the checkout
use code yola
for everyone out there i won't say it
fully yet
when you showed me this guy
i asked my little brother my little
brother's on the internet heavy
yeah and i go do you know and i said the
name he goes
yes why i'm like why do you know that
name thomas i go
so you know who it is my favorite my
favorite youtuber
brock was like ah he was tripping cause
and then you showed me this kid i
haven't said the name it you showed me
this kid and i go
oh this [ __ ] is entertaining and
i asked you did you do drugs
no do you smoke nope he's going to be
very successful and so how did you start
working with danny duncan
because i know a lot of people that
follow us love them
so danny came from the [ __ ]
from the ground up couch surfing
sleeping in floors
eating peanut butter and jellies every
day because he didn't have money to buy
food so you just buy like a big loaf of
bread
and like peanut butter and jelly and
like cams and [ __ ] like
you mean like regular life no no no like
literally that's all he would buy like
that's all he had like like i was like
yo this guy's eating he grew up in
merced
like whoa but uh yeah man i remember
like danny used to come at to the
warehouse
and this is how i met danny oh really
yes he looked
full circle again so i met danny
actually through another guy named chris
chan
he's like another skater yeah yeah so
he's the kid i saw
at echo park there was this guy standing
on the board and like
recording himself sliding and go this
kid's gonna fall in the [ __ ] water
and i post on my snap yeah they had like
5 000 people that's [ __ ] chris chad
yeah i have no clue who that is so yeah
so trip
out so chris chan uh that's another wild
story itself you know like
i i like i said i always been that type
of dude that i knew
who was gonna be good at whatever they
were doing you know
and i always had faith in danny like i
knew danny
like he was starting with his youtube
channel and i knew he was like wild and
crazy and down like regardless
he didn't smoke weed and a drink like
you said like he was just
down you know like he was down for
whatever like he was just like [ __ ] it
i'm down you know
and he used to stretch everybody
could he just be a physical therapist he
used to be yeah he used to be like
really like into like therapy and all
that [ __ ] so he knew
like how to stretch so he started
stretching all these athletes and pros
and that's how he got in his name like
oh danny danny
everybody used to call him danny the
stretch guy i literally i think i had
him on my phone
like for danny the stretch guy i swear
no way i had him on my phone for a while
like that but he got a new phone so
whatever but um um so yeah
so danny he used to come to the
warehouse and i used to hook him up with
clothes and all that
used to send them some boxes in florida
and uh
i remember bro like i'm not gonna lie
my bad that was you yeah yeah i just
pulled up his [ __ ] channel here and
this [ __ ] started playing oh my oh i
thought that was something outside my
band
yeah so um danny right so
i remember like the the whole marketing
team and everybody's
telling me like yo like that guy is
crazy man
like i don't know man like
he shouldn't be giving him too much [ __ ]
or whatever i was like they didn't like
what he was doing too much
kind of yeah they thought he was
probably like annoying or something you
know i don't know man it's just
some people have they have a certain
taste to what they want to give their
brand to but
you know like like it's like on the
jackass style he was going
to jackass without the popularity yet
yeah but he was growing i was
i knew he was going to be you could see
it yeah of course it's [ __ ] funny
yeah
so and like the the dude is that
like if you think like the dude is not
like that off cameras no he's really
like that off camera it's like
you don't even need a camera on him but
he's gonna do all of that [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
so um i i always
like knew he was gonna [ __ ] kill it
he was growing a lot
in youtube and then he had his
i remember this is how it all like
happened like
he had his first little like pop-up like
hey
like you know his youtube's popping now
so he's like hey
mimi at echo park on sunset
sunset and echo park literally in the
corner
and he ran in like this little uh
i think it was like a hair salon and he
was like yo
bro i need help i was like what you need
he's like i just need a dj
come and come and play some tunes bro
the trap [ __ ] that
you know cause i was playing i was
listening to all the dope [ __ ] music
the trap [ __ ]
the kids were like oh what is this you
know and
like that turned up [ __ ] you know and
that's how i slowly
became danny's tour dj
you know like and then now we just every
time he
wants to go on tour he just hits me up
like yo pull up
because last time because like i said my
little brother is a big fan
and he knows that so when they were on
tour last time i was just chilling
randomly with my little brother
and my mom and this whole face times me
and he's with danny and it was
so marty to see my little brother's face
when i handed him the [ __ ] phone and
it was danny duncan
my brother he pretty much just exploded
like his whole body just from happiness
it was his screensaver his screenshot it
was a screensaver for like a year and a
half
yeah and we're actually uh like it's
just it's one of those things like
uh thank you for doing that [ __ ]
my little brother is so excited
and you're about to go back on tour yeah
september 24th
so omar's danny's dj
dj all right so have you seen any of his
vid
did you see any of it yet i don't know
anything about him all he does
is and he's just an entertaining he's
jackass without the danger without the
cussing
without the dicks and family friendly so
the moms are like
yeah his brand's called virginity rocks
sage when he goes and performs live
cut your [ __ ] hair off battles
everybody and gladiator [ __ ]
they play [ __ ] music they do a bunch
of activities he has like eight friends
on the channel
it's just marty marty when i tell you
this fool is making money
just being himself so it's like a play
yo look no it's
all these goddamn dates that's because
it's gonna be
look at all the vips sold out bro
everything
i'm just trying to figure like that's
i've never heard of this before
you know how you like we have fans like
yo thomas your fans are [ __ ]
wild like yeah i know yo by the way man
[ __ ] wild bro all right like in the
terms of like
he doesn't do drugs so if you're 12 you
can come to the show
yeah if you're 14 you can come to the
show there's nothing that has to do with
drugs
so much bigger bro it's so much bigger
than what we have okay okay
this is all i gotta say this
is all right so everybody's like danny
danny
danny when he wants to win i guess you
know before we come out
you know the first thing i do all i have
to do
i know what you do [ __ ] and they
were like oh my god i was like
oh my [ __ ]
no because he says stupid [ __ ] like that
they say a bunch of stuff
marty when i tell you that
for 12 year olds no but it is but it's
for kids that just started cussing
and college kids and i mean i'm i'm 31.
and i'm like yo that's your job the new
danny duncan
danny duncan spells videos out let me
see what he did today
last time he went and rented out these
like tricycles you ride in the thing and
just
destroyed them throughout the city of
san francisco i think
but he's making so much money goes oh
just pay for it because he's like oh how
much is it gonna be okay i'll cover the
cost
thank you and it's so
but he's got money but he'll go to a
close fast food restaurant go hey uh how
much
this is gonna cost for me to be able to
make my own food and film it okay cool
here
so we're in the back of subway right now
it's like [ __ ] that you want to do
but but you can't you don't
sometimes they just let him do it though
oh because he's
he's very very charismatic yeah he talks
so [ __ ] well because i've been there
do this talking to somebody and talk to
her
like all right i'm hopping over it's so
good he's so outgoing it's so curious
man he's so
he's what every kid wants to be like in
school class clown
but he's very articulate when he speaks
he's
he's a winning recipe how does he rank
against the other like top like
youtubers with fan base wise i think
he's the biggest fan base
i don't know anything about youtube he's
just himself it's just a strong fan base
man
it's the people really love it you know
how like people love our [ __ ]
yeah if we could appeal to everyone
all right so is he he's bigger than
logan paul uh i'm not in terms of money
or anything but
i guarantee if logan paul walks down the
street his fans are there they're like
yo whoa can i get a picture
if they show up everyone's gonna start
ripping his [ __ ] clothes up gotcha
the last show they beat his car to
[ __ ]
death like they destroyed his car
because it was in the parking lot
he's like yeah you guys can hit it and
then it went to what he couldn't even
drive it
yeah he couldn't even drive it totally
but he just bought another one
but it's it's like that at this point
yeah it's like good pranks like oh i'm
saying i'm gonna prank my sister
by throwing her car off a [ __ ] bridge
yeah and then she turned around and i
bought her a brand new car
yeah oh okay cool you still got to have
fun and you said what you do with money
yeah yes yeah now but before it's just
charismatic vlog he's just a
he's a funny guy the one i saw that got
me hooked was was uh he was
went and hired like 12 dudes from home
depot to play baseball yeah
yeah yeah football he's like yo you guys
how much you charged all right cool you
guys we're just gonna play football
yeah and then go swim and record the
whole thing and we'll switch
it's just like yo bought everybody
chick-fil-a
you just you just were was it him that
you were saying like look at how he
how he like edited i like how this looks
yes
so what's his what's his production
values he got a whole team or is he like
minimal uh
he just uh to be honest he just has a
guy that sticks aside
to he's been a sidekick just camera like
um
just like you and marty pretty much but
like
um the edits aren't crazy there's only
like
two percent of the whole video is edited
cool so yeah so
but it looks good now now that he's
obviously bigger and he has like
other talented people around him he has
two uh
he has two filmers right but the other
one catches
uh he had probably has another vision i
i just seen it recently because
i've i haven't been around him because
of kobe and all that stuff so he's been
in florida
and when uh he did a little pop-up in
fairfax recently
he had two filmers like one shooting
photos like really good at shooting dope
ass photos
and the other guy was shooting like the
the b
camera and then his main dude who had
the main one you know good so four
four person team with the host yeah
that's great yeah
and then his runners you could fit in
one car
but they're all his friends up you know
what i'm saying like that's great yeah
yeah but he's getting paid so much like
yo don't worry about that
just help me yeah yeah i got you covered
yeah yeah
yeah it's great that's what i love about
you yes great yeah
he's dope he's amazing yeah so
that's how you got involved with him i
did not know yeah so we always went like
a 15 minute
well i don't cause people always tag me
in his [ __ ] i don't even know who this
dude is
yeah yeah it's danny it's funny
i when i watched your house the other
day yo this
me for me to you like i get why you're
so popular and yeah
i totally understand i uh she went on
tour for three [ __ ] months
yeah yeah so so this was gonna be on
tour for three months he's got the
virginity rocks that's the brand
ass he's got the again and the yang gone
i respect the yin
and the yay i actually have virginity
rocks tattooed
right there from the last tour on his
arm how did that start i saw that in
[ __ ] sears or something bro it's big
i'm probably sounding
like that as [ __ ] right now no no no no
i'm shocked cam don't watch him
i'm gonna be honest with he does
probably does yeah his son
if there's if they're screaming about
[ __ ] and [ __ ] he's probably not
watching them
no that's not like the whole thing
that's not it's like a little like
tagline for the kids that are older yeah
it's not for everybody not
every kid saying the [ __ ] when he
uploads to youtube does he check the
maid for kids
i do not know i don't know that's like
there's nothing to tell me that it's not
there's nothing to tell me i don't know
i don't know i don't know because uh
there's comments if you have made for
kids there's no comments
damn we just went on 20 [ __ ] minutes
of that [ __ ] you're going on another
tour starts when
uh september 26
6 i think for everyone out there that's
going to go to this tour stop and say
what up to this dude oh no twenty's
gonna be the dj september 24th
you'll be the guy looking like baby
sinclair for the dinosaurs yeah and
he'll just be up there doing this so
what do you go up with when you're djing
huh what do you go up with you got like
some turntables or some [ __ ] uh
i just use uh pioneers uh they're like
uh
those like cdjs okay they're not really
cdjs they're more like that controller
you know
like that portable one and [ __ ] it's a
pioneer
sddj yeah
like one of those oh god you got you got
you like it's really small
instead of taking the whole big heavy
unit you take this little like
not not folder size but like like let's
say
oh i get it decent size you know what
i'm saying
i think you got morty yeah and you know
it's better because
when you're on tour you don't want to
pack all this [ __ ] you know you want to
pack light
that's the thing like you want to have a
backup for everything you want to be
prepared
but hey what did they
remember what happened to you on tour
last time
is that involved in any video no
you sure that it's you're in the vlog we
had to go to the hospital
uh there's a blog where i went to the
hospital
is that in there somewhere no
don't play dumb yeah next question
for all the fans out there you guys
already saw it you
you need to give me a million dollars
for that
they didn't show it all no they didn't
show nothing they just showed you
walking back huh
mm-hmm this weed's getting my throat me
too
weird sorry for everyone in the car just
listen to two dudes
yeah um sorry sorry sorry sorry no i um
they didn't they didn't put none of that
and then he knows not to
put into that i passed the [ __ ] out at
uh
i didn't get too [ __ ] up at one of the
shows and in the vlog he's there
and the next cut is seven hours later
he's walking with a hospital hand on him
[ __ ] you guys half naked yo it's so
[ __ ] funny no dude i thought i got
roofied and [ __ ] and you didn't
no well i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened dude i saw it i didn't get
drunk nothing
i didn't get drunk nothing bro really i
thought you were shitfaced no
hell no they never that's not funny that
no no no dude i thought i got [ __ ]
roofied in
orlando or some [ __ ] because look trip
out we had performed at this [ __ ]
club in orlando and whatever we left and
then the manager said yo
you guys can come back and enjoy the
[ __ ] reggaeton party
and i was like oh hell yeah you know
i was like i'm gonna go to that [ __ ] i'm
gonna see what's up
i want to see the vibe in orlando
bro i don't know bro they were giving
free drinks
and i got one drink
and that's right that's all it took one
drink
that sucks yeah you didn't tell me that
part yeah yeah it's not nearly as funny
yeah
you got drugs no i mean the other part
was funny after you know
because everybody was laughing
because i said i haven't had meat in
like two years
and it was like because i i hadn't
stopped eating meat like
you hadn't been all yeah yeah i know you
personally
and i said that and i passed out
yo so in short
that's how you met him doing the dj you
start touring again in since uh
september
all the way across all across the
country yeah yeah yeah nice nice so
dannyduncan69.com
all right well if you guys go to the
show uh do me a favor
pull up let's say what up say what up
say hi
hello i'll be in the near city i don't
know
sitting near you high i'm high [ __ ]
that's what i can see it on your face
and those joints aren't fully done so i
could tell you're high
um hello i didn't even kill that last
puff [ __ ] me up right look at my
joint
oh yeah
all right on to the next one next
question next question next question
so what are we doing this comes in full
circle all right you're not
you're now becoming friends with all
these people all these rappers all these
entertainers doing all this stuff
you're just to do a diamond you're just
the guy doing this [ __ ] and then
one day your jerk ass text me goes check
out this little song i made and you made
it this
mark did i ever tell you this he made a
little song on his [ __ ]
phone on an app and he was it sounds
pretty sick right
he sent it to me and i go yo this is
actually
[ __ ] awesome this is super [ __ ]
cool
yeah he sent me a little it's like dude
i'm like it's did you make this on your
fingers i made it on my phone's app
where you just
and you click all the beats and this and
like his voice on it i'm like
this is actually very cool bro he goes
yeah i think i'm gonna try to do
something so he went to first and then
you take off take over from there
what happened after after you sent me
that i go this is tight
the next day you went to first yeah and
then take it from there so
i i made the song i used to uh
garageband on my phone
and uh i pretty much end up learning it
how to do it and it was kind of easy
it just you can put even like uh
make the sounds and switch them and
different keys kind of like
fl studios and the regular beat making
you know program and i made the song
and i was like dude i kept on listening
to it listening to it listening to it
and i was like all right that's why i
sent it to you
like check this out and then you said
dude it's actually pretty good i sent it
first and first i was like yo bro what
what are you gonna do with this you know
like and you're not a musician i mean
you
yes but you're not a musician in that
term you just know these guys as
friends yeah yeah and then they're like
wait what this you made this
yeah yeah you piece of [ __ ] yeah but
like
music has always been like in my life
i've been doing music since a kid like
in other words i've been playing in
bands since like middle school yeah
that's rock bands and all that [ __ ]
metal [ __ ] you know
like i learned how to play guitar by
myself keyboard
everything metal [ __ ] versus the stuff
we all know
is not in the same room of course but i
i was always like
music in tune with everyone 100 i get
that i get that but i'm talking about
from their perspective like
oh omar's coming over wait wait you made
this [ __ ] yeah oh yeah yeah
right now yeah because you have a
producer making [ __ ] grammy-nominated
hits yeah yeah and it's just your friend
yeah and now you're making sure that he
can go oh i can work
we uh almost got nominated for one uh
yeah i helped help write and he produced
it and all that he gave me
he's like yo this uh uh girl she's like
she's really [ __ ] dope you should
help her with some words if you can
she was doing some song and then i did
and that [ __ ] was
dope as [ __ ] track and look look at
the [ __ ] that can happen by just helping
you know or whatever you know i didn't
see nothing of it i never
seen nothing other like i don't think
like oh i'm going to do this in
in hopes of nah [ __ ] that i just do it
you know
like i don't care like we'll see what
happens after
[ __ ] it yeah so and that's how i
no so i did the music to go back you
went to first with that
little thing on your phone yeah so i
went to him with that on my phone and he
was like all right
i got it and then he like made another
beat or whatever and then he's like now
wrapped to this or whatever
how'd you go over it yeah so like so
then he
uh one day i shot him a song
which was like gal okay was the first
song that i did right
i sent it to him he's like bro what the
[ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] have you been doing you
know and i was doing this
and my [ __ ] i was doing this in my
living room at that time
and at that time i'm gonna keep it a
buck i was
also pissed off you know like not pissed
but like
also mad because like i'm mad i mean
like sad and
mad because like at that time like
i had separated from diamond you know so
it felt like
a relationship almost like that i broke
up you know like damn
i mean they're my boys still you know
everybody we're all cool and [ __ ]
but i felt like damn i broke up with a
girl you know like type [ __ ] you know
because i i was in there for like six
years you know
like doing all this [ __ ] you know like
so then i was like [ __ ] it i'm gonna
make i'm gonna go make music now you
know
so then i started making music and
that's when i made rachet on
make ratchet reggaeton music put it
trapped
at royalton music put it together and
create the sound with
spanish and atlanta producer which is
fki
first so he's like dude what this was
the first time i heard that style music
and now i hear the [ __ ] i hear it a lot
yeah exactly to be honest yeah yeah i
had never heard it before you sent me
that yeah so
i knew regathon was coming on his way
back you know i knew it was
because i i like to stay like i said in
tune
to what the streets is listening to in
puerto rico whatever
like and i [ __ ] knew readathon was
going to come back
because everybody was starting to like
to play the old stuff in the radio
and like there was this new artist
coming up at the time like osuna
jay balbin jay bauman wasn't that big
yet you know what i'm saying it was just
like his first music videos uh
when he started i was like oh [ __ ] it's
coming back
so i was like all right ratchet man it's
gonna
transform me to rachet now you know like
uh
i don't want to be a [ __ ] uh the
the plug linking fools no more and i
want to
do something for myself now and let's
see what i can do you know
and so i went to first and we did that
and you know how destiny works man
if you just he told me like if you just
do what you have to do
everything will work out eventually you
know just be patient
and so i kept on making a lot music more
music
like so after you after you redid your
first song and you sent it to me
it's sounding a whole different song
yeah yeah but like your [ __ ] was tight
and then you just elevated the
[ __ ] yeah and what do you say it's a
radio song
yeah that's a [ __ ] that's [ __ ] you
hear on the radio or during a commercial
yeah like it sounded legit like like a
radio yeah
bro so then to the point where like he
obviously made it better you know he's a
[ __ ] piece the best
um one day he he like bro
don't trip something's happening you
know like just don't trip he didn't
really want to tell me or like jinx
anything
and somehow [ __ ] dude i got a record
deal
[ __ ] i got signed a republic because
of that you know like one
[ __ ] song well the the song wasn't
even [ __ ]
out it wasn't even out party and they
gave him a deal republican gave him a
[ __ ] wreck not any small one
we're playing a record deal yeah off one
song i was standing
outside on like eighth street across the
street from the [ __ ]
laser tag place when you called me and i
remember exactly where i was like wait
what what'd you say you got a what
i remember where i was at when you
called me no [ __ ] yeah
yeah dude that was like what the [ __ ] no
[ __ ] way
like so tight dude and and i at that
time i was like oh hell no like i
i gotta go hard now you know like holy
[ __ ] you know
like i didn't even know like damn what
the [ __ ]
you were just smoking weed and you made
some [ __ ] on your phone and then i went
to the studio
and it's like by the way guys i have
this guy he's my friend he's making
music you should get the spanish artist
signed
yeah then they got yeah
well it wasn't even no it wasn't even
like how fast
i don't i don't think it happened like
that i think they were like
i think just played he was just playing
like uh i think
the vice president at the time um
he uh went to the studio and he was
hearing like oh what you've been working
on type [ __ ] you know
and then my song stumbled upon
and they're like what is that you know
mm-hmm
and then at that time i also had like a
little other sample and you could hear i
only had
two i only had two remember your second
one second one's the heart trap yeah
the knock ones yeah yeah yeah so they
were like what the [ __ ] is this that
[ __ ] sounds
ridiculous bro and then at the time also
i had
uh hit up my homies uh shoreline and
[ __ ] phoenix
and i was like yo bro we should get on
the song and he's like yeah yeah
[ __ ] it let's do it you're the guy
linking all these guys they're your
friends and then they're like wait
you're making good
music now yeah let's let's work
shoreline is [ __ ] huge
but it's so it work it's like me going
you're gonna grow weed oh yeah i know a
lot of growers
so before too like before i really got
into the music i recorded a [ __ ] play
with cardi music video
oh you did yeah with fat man key it's
called ghost
batman key play bacardi and at the end
of the video you'll see the ratchet man
logo
directed by ratchet no way i swear
you can check on youtube if you want
that's awesome playboy cardi
i didn't know who he was and you're like
yeah this phone is weed and i go alright
i know who to call don't you
yeah so that's the only time i knew he
was so yeah it's crazy like
you know so from doing that i was like
[ __ ] i know all these people you know
like what the [ __ ] like i know the
sunny like i could try to ask sunny for
a beat or something now
you know
to the point where i [ __ ] i uh
i have a song where like first and my
conan produced two that you know like
you know like it's crazy it was crazy
and i was like damn
i'm really [ __ ] in this [ __ ] yeah you
know my turn
yeah yeah you know i was [ __ ]
tripping bro like
there was a time where the the label
sent me to the lion grammys it was my
first language i remember
well you remember when you things
happened you let me know
yeah and i'm at home going and i have a
great memory or where i was when you
told me latin grammys yeah yeah yeah
i remember everything so that when they
sent me the grammys bro
i started tripping out because i'm like
looking around i'm like
holy [ __ ] bat bunnies right there jay
baldwin's right there
rosalia's right there like everyone was
just around me and i'm just like
you got the sound that they want
honestly bro i'm going to be honest
that's what i hear now anytime i hear
spanish music
it sounds like your [ __ ] they they have
a
commercial sound they have the hits
that that oh yeah
so it's like a little different you know
um
but those dudes uh i was around those
dudes in my head i was like holy [ __ ]
dude like this is
[ __ ] insane you know [ __ ] three
months ago yeah
i remember i even bumped into like dj
lachetto he's all over the radio i
bumped into him
the first time when i met him like it
was like somewhere in the land grammys
while we were all doing interviews he
was going to a different room i was
going to a different room
i had my savvy flag he had a mexican
flag we're like what up primo
and i said what up and yeah that's the
first time i met dj lechero 2.
like it was it was a crazy experience
like to be around like a bunch of people
yeah and then i was like
brand new they didn't know me type [ __ ]
i was just this chubby guy
like long hair [ __ ] wearing
[Music]
all of a sudden i'm wearing expensive
[ __ ] without even wanting to buy this
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying i'm like
[ __ ] dude you know like i'm not sure
this was that's a metal shirt
and everything else flashes well now
everybody's [ __ ] wearing yeah but
your real metal shirt the one that you
wore eight years ago
no i know but they're calling it vintage
i don't know oh you would look like you
paid 400 bucks for it yeah on mine yeah
that's crazy dude everybody is wearing
metal shirts now now
but that's now's the trend you know i
remember bro back in the day
when we went to a like a like uh i think
we were going to like a club in
hollywood right they didn't [ __ ] let
me in because i was wearing a metal
shirt
right but shout out to jerry lorenzo but
jerry lorenzo comes [ __ ] nike
designer jerry lorenzo fear of god with
a metallica [ __ ] fear of god's shirt
ripped up
more ripped than mine and he walks right
in
and we're like huh
rice's
what oh hell no and i was like man
whatever
i i was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah i left
i was like i'm not even off
maybe my [ __ ] was cannibal corpse
[ __ ] bloody [ __ ] you know i was like
oh okay
i get it you know i don't want to
cannibal corpse
i get i get it yeah but yeah so
it's [ __ ] insane man i [ __ ] been
around the room with a bunch of [ __ ]
people because of this [ __ ] because of
music
and for for everyone at home i know that
a lot of them that are
super fans like so wait he's making
spanish music and you like to talk
the best thing ever marty you ready the
best thing ever
was when i finally saw this phone person
we're chilling every other day anyway
but when i finally saw him in person
after he showed me the song
i had this full play and he's doing this
every line
blah blah blah blah he song's playing he
goes and he's reciting it in
english to me so i know what he's saying
i go hey what are you saying and you
press pause so something something
something something
and then you play it again and spanish
music's playing again then you press
pause
and then like then and then i then like
this then i this like oh
so you're like you're talking about some
chick like she's like a gold digger like
oh
yeah get it now he's lying for line
telling me in english because i didn't
know what the [ __ ] he's saying
i just know the sound was like oh [ __ ]
this is great
yeah i just didn't know the words and
then that's when i left my second
spanish
lesson yeah that was when this fool
started doing music
that that was [ __ ] crazy man one
[ __ ] song man it literally takes
to anyone making music producers which a
lot of people do
that follow us i've seen it really check
it out it really only takes
one [ __ ] song or something really
catchy
like to the point where people are
becoming famous off
tick tock they make a catchy little song
yeah people are like where is this song
make it or finish it
next thing you know it has [ __ ] half
a million views because tick tock
on their spotify you know what i'm
saying doesn't matter like
from there you have to go with the
current not against the current you just
got to make another song
you know keep doing another song you
know like
i get it that's pretty much i feel like
it only takes one you know where can
people find your music my music you can
get it on spotify
itunes amazon and how do you spell it
for everyone out there it's ratchet tone
but
it's wrestling it's a word ratchet
ratchet
and owen oh and it's got that little you
know that
no latin squiggle line no that's just on
the logo that's just how
like that i don't even know what it's
called accent line yeah just
ratchet i think yeah
[Laughter]
that's the end with a little squiggle
all right i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about
that's ryan sickler he said that oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah you could you can get it
all platforms youtube
all that you oh so you're youtube and
it's not we related we can actually link
it it'll be in the description
guys we'll leave your description uh
your link and everything in the
description
marty i have to guess how long we've
been talking
oh 146. ooh i felt the one
for something yeah i don't know why just
inside i can't see this yeah
no you listen you've hit it spot on
before like 152
it feels like yeah 152. yeah
i just can't see this the time because
it's not the time's blocked i know it's
like oh [ __ ] halloween oh hell no get
the [ __ ] out yeah
um so damn uh i will be going to the
first the danny duncan show in l.a
wherever you do
yeah yeah dude when i went to the last
danny duncan show there were so many
fans of ours there
yeah it was awesome there was so many of
our fans like yo
what the [ __ ] are you here like i'm in
the 21 and up section with the parents
like i'm over here with all the dads my
little brother
and his yeah and his and his homie so he
got us like moving backstage and like my
brother got to meet
everybody it's just a good experience
you know as a kid
it's my anti-brett favre experience all
right that's what i want to give to
everyone yeah i don't want you to be
disappointed
so he did you the greatest gift though
yep yeah everything i could do for my
brother my homies was like yo
like the first time i met chavo i didn't
tell this fool because he's a system of
down fanatic too
yeah and he just went and saw him in
vegas and my friend's like you want to
interview shabo it's like three years
ago before i ever
was ever my friend and i facetimed him
like yo
uh before mikey all my friends a fan he
just said hi on facetime
i was pushing it don't ask people for
that the first time i was pushing it
because it was my friends i'm like nah i
got it's got to happen yeah
it's gotta happen and i facetimed him
with this one he was not prepared
anyway i was in my bed no shirt type
[ __ ] my hair all
[ __ ] up i don't care has to be done oh
hell no
it's not as bad as we we met warren g
one night while we were out
and april walked up to him warren
[ __ ] g april walks up to him and goes
my mom loves you
no i don't know maybe she [ __ ] had
regulators
at one point
regularly yo my mom's like if you ever
have mike tyson on you better
[ __ ] let me be in the room she will
not stop
right now next week when this comes out
in the chat live chat my mom's watching
obviously mom i know you're watching
right now she's in every chat
you can't be here mike tyson's here
she's just her enticing fist fighting
oh [ __ ] no no no no
i can't i broke my back she wins finally
she wins uh my dice is too cool bro no
my mom's a fanatic she's an actual
boxing fan so it's like
i can't have you around your super fan
you're a super and i don't want you to
every time you lashes
over there you know what i'm saying
i have that mom uh sorry we're in a way
different topic
my bad so uh all right cool closer to
you so what's up what's up with these
impromptu sports events you do
soccer oh it comes from our skating day
what soccer he said i gotta get out and
start doing stuff well yeah yeah yeah
well
i actually uh started playing a lot of
soccer
recently and started going to a lot of
soccer games uh
uh oh we'll vlog it we'll vlog it yeah
yeah we're gonna
we're gonna go to the soccer game yeah
we're gonna do a blog proper blog and
we're gonna go
to soccer field and see thomas try to
play
i'm really good at soccer [ __ ] you uh
what me these guys are pretty good
i used to play soccer [ __ ] all right
we'll see
and everybody thinks they're good we saw
some dudes we got like four
people by ourselves oh no no i'm trying
i'm trashed compared to good guys
i'm like pretty good yeah yeah i i'm
ready
yeah i've been uh yeah i also play
basketball too
so yeah i know we all know that from
escape vlog you made a bunch of them in
a row
yeah i was the best
[Laughter]
you know just trying to be more active
but yeah exactly so yeah this wasn't
like throwing soccer game meets
like pick up games but just soccer
pickup games yeah it's pretty cool
that's pretty cool
that's pretty cool like that yeah yeah
yeah yeah you just played college
basketball we still haven't played
basketball yet man
it needs to happen and it's sick because
you can see la like
all like downtown like sick when it's
like the sun's going down it's not it's
just falling bro to get active and do
yeah
it's just fun [ __ ] fun oh yeah you
don't even feel like you're running
until you're done every thursday every
thursday really
every thursday i play 6 p.m every
thursday
when you set it like that i just imagine
you're like i'm just thinking drone
shots
yeah gimbal out there that should have
been sad it's [ __ ]
no bro it's beautiful and it's like
under the like a big old bridge you know
we're born and raised hit that big old
[ __ ] punk party
in l.a oh it's right there literally
close to it bro it's like it's beautiful
i was just talking about that party to
my sister actually yeah yeah it's just
owner right that [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a sick ass spot bro it's there's
too much sickness out there for me to be
going in those crowds everybody's
touching my speaking but no
but no but this is a fun scene yeah i
know bro
soccer episode for sure it's gonna be
amazing
pull up all right well after we saw
mcgregor break his leg i decided not to
do the skate vlog but we were supposed
to go skate with jaron and who else
baby fabian and i think guy was going to
go marcia
mariano mariano right yeah yeah
goddammit mcgregor
dude remember he broke his leg and i
went i'm not [ __ ] doing the escape
vlog
i'm done man that scared me to death i
can't do it i know i'll do it but i
don't want to be hitting no ramps we're
supposed to do a [ __ ]
just skating with princess i'll go play
soccer yeah go
play play soccer yeah i've been playing
soccer and going to these soccer games
like lafc and like i went into the el
salvador game because of my friend fifa
like he's been like
he played soccer like him and his
brother his brother's like a coach for
kids his name is fifa
yeah literally fifa he that's his rapper
named fifa oh
oh oh yeah he's born
yeah my son he's over here called
national basketball association
uh his name is nba young boy
that's different bro
but nah um yeah so i just been you know
trying to stay active and play
play more how the [ __ ] do we get oh you
asked what's up with these soccer
experiences
but yeah and nothing like that we'll do
this blog later
um so we can find you on spotify itunes
everything youtube is ratchet tone yeah
all one word same thing
same thing okay so uh twitch oh yeah
twitch
so real quick you guys haven't seen
i know you guys can see on the news
[ __ ] they're like why is postman
playing magic
it's because of this [ __ ] jerk i call
this fool i'm not really mean i don't
mean you're a nerd but i have to say
every time you bring up magical you
[ __ ] hey because it's funny to me to
call you a nerd
like dude there's a nerdy thing you've
got [ __ ] yeah and it's magic
i love magic i know you do every time he
goes to my house he goes to [ __ ]
uh he goes to a store to buy magic cards
every [ __ ] time
he's talking about like magic the card
game magic together
so post malone's hell into that because
of this [ __ ] dude he got him into
this [ __ ] he [ __ ]
facetimed me and he's like dude what's
up
i'm gonna beat you up when i see you and
i was like what are you talking about
he's like so i heard you uh play magic
and i was like
[ __ ] yeah play magic what's up he's like
come over to my uh come over to my hotel
let's play
and i was like are you sure sure you
want to get destroyed
like are you sure i was like i'm gonna
play really dirty he's like all right
what do you have
he's asking you for the car i was like i
play with this type of style
in fact and i hit you 10 times you're
dead like
literally and he was like he was just
like
oh you bastard and then people showed up
to the hotel to the point where he's
like he called me back he was like hey
uh let's just play tomorrow or he's like
i don't got those cards yet maybe i
should play tomorrow
well i don't know maybe but he told me
like hey there's people coming
and yeah then smitty back to smitty he
facetimed me like
where you at what the [ __ ] and then
everybody start pulling up so
it wasn't the time to play magic i just
think gathering in the middle of the
rapper party yeah i don't think he
probably
yeah so he was like nah hit me he's
funny as [ __ ] yeah yeah so he was like
hit me tomorrow and let's get this game
in
boom tomorrow comes [ __ ] goes
too [ __ ]
uh what's that [ __ ] called um you're
gonna say
frankincense or something like that yeah
frankincense is like
a place where they sell like all types
of frank and sons
yeah yeah i thought you were trying to
say the word frankincense no no i was so
confused right no no no no
frankincense and um they sell all these
like retro stuff
[ __ ] cards and all that [ __ ] magic
pokemon oh so like i said he needed to
go re-up on cars to beat your ass
yeah so he went bought some [ __ ]
cards
next thing you know he's all over tmz
because he's buying magic cards and all
kinds of [ __ ]
and i was like holy [ __ ] i opened up the
wormhole
something different you know like nerdy
all the nerds felt like they won like oh
my god their shit's [ __ ] great and
then
i was like [ __ ] yeah like that's just
magics that's all about just have fun
and
i don't care man i'm just there to play
and have fun like yeah
so on twitch yeah magic yeah i'll be
playing magic games with people from
like new york
[ __ ] it's just i love the fact that i
love magic so
[ __ ] much yeah because it's like the
nerdy thing
of everyone somebody's always got one
little thing you gotta be like bro
it's always got something it's like as
weird as this sounds like they just did
this [ __ ] dungeon dragons collab
like literally i never played that
either yeah i mean i never played that
i've never tried it i never played it
too but
they just did magic collab and i tried
pokemon but
i haven't bought into it yet so you play
pokemon [ __ ] when you're a kid too i
used to play pokemon i tried it was just
too hard to get into like
to me it was dropping oh imagine the
action
yeah [ __ ] you let's play video games
i like yu-gi-oh [ __ ] you know yeah when
you came out i was well past it
i was writing watching too much wwf yeah
yeah playing with wrestlers physical
tangible slams
so you were like [ __ ] breaking toys
apart
like said never no i took care of mine
but i did full-on wrestling matches uh
oh yeah you still have your little case
yeah you're right he was archiving his
yeah yeah yeah he was he started we're
housing them they're still
yeah they're still i was that kid
he still has shots are clean too yeah
on odd touch oh i gave rosie's nephew
two of my toys out of the chest when i
was here
and i did not get more croft and
spiderman back
oh my god i need my toys back sorry this
is not podcast relevant at all sorry
about that
all right man so that's why i put
matching together imagine the gathering
yeah into a conversation you guys want
to [ __ ] play
let's [ __ ] do it every time we have
one of my actual friends come on here
we're just going to put a fake phone
thing it looks like we're facetiming
yeah
every time me and you do a solo you
should just crop in the phone
how cool of a edit would that be uh-huh
every time you go back to you it's just
me in the corner up top
i've actually been thinking about that
yeah yeah it's a picture
of tight yeah i don't know we said that
um
damn dude we we just talked for two
hours right yeah
about nothing
i love no i love your story because it's
like
you're somebody that's like i'm not any
one thing i dabble in a bunch of
different things because my muscle kind
of extends across
yeah yeah and i tell people all the time
when you can add value to other people
yeah that's how you stay around for a
long time bro they're
not worried about only being the star of
the show but it's about
you know you gotta have skills hell yeah
and i and i like the community bro they
accepted me for
who i am they're like they they they
throw some jabs in there they're like
hey man you have some free time from
your rapper stuff yeah
like it's just funny bro like it's just
like a little community and they're cool
bro like
for example i posted this thing oh i
need these little few cards
everyone dm me like i got them for you
just send me addresses
by the way these are not prescriptive
these are five dollars oh by the way uh
omar put these glasses
on and became a reggaeton artist because
five minutes before
that see what five dollars could make a
difference you know it's five dollars
really changes your whole game
yeah it's about compliments they might
be bootleg but
you know you look like you're trying to
try to sell me depth
outdoor packs at 22. those glasses tell
me
you tax people with weed especially with
this sf hat huh
with that sf hat and those tells me
you're going to do this a lot while you
talk absolutely
rub your hands i should have put a big
ponytail too if you had a ponytail
you might have a uzi in your car or a
pistol with a really long extended clip
that's the bay area fools with just the
chain
yeah they have the plain shirt the hat
and the hair with the braids
those are the fools that have the
automatic guns
and everybody at home that i just
described from the bay is going
yep yep that's exactly right my hair you
forgot the grill
too yeah but that's mainly like the
asian dudes at the grill the oakland
fool's
whatever happened ah i miss never i was
running pretty good yeah
well let's leave it at that yeah what
happened to you sale where's he sale at
obviously that phone two years man
um so everybody you can find all your
stuff it's linked in the description
yes sir all right all right that was
good that's good that's a good episode
thank you man thank you
so uh we're gonna open up for us at our
first live show
for sure he's going to open up he's just
going to do magic on openings
that's what i meant yeah no well i would
press play
and then perform and then run back to
the dj and then press play
oh that'd be sick i'll be sick you know
one man and you all like little beasts
like little b he does that he presses
play goes in front raps and it goes back
and dj's
will be what happened a little bit where
is he at base god i haven't seen him in
so long i don't know
getting pictures of feet sent to him i
know what a wild twitter to have that's
all he just played yeah that's all he
photos
oh he goes it's crazy he's a wild ass
dude
the last time i think he was on the mac
miller album last thing i heard from him
dude i was uh out of subject but i was
there when he got jumped in the bay bro
oh and they beat when they punched him
who punches a little b i have no idea
oh that's crazy you can do your research
i'm not gonna say go to
no i i remember when it happened they
jumped up and [ __ ] and i seen him and he
came out on stage he was like
man i love y'all man i just want to give
you a hug
come on stage bro give me my backpack so
i could perform for the people
they took his backpack and [ __ ] so he
couldn't perform
but yeah i love y'all man you say i love
you he's the most positive person
he's like the the thing that i loved
about what he said he's like come on man
they just jumped me
i was here one deep one deep
i remember that everyone else damn the
internet makes
your life go by so fast that was years
ago yeah oh damn
oh damn oh damn and then you remember my
video yeah i was there at the rolling
lounge and all that [ __ ]
and i seen that [ __ ] uh cause you took
me to the smokers
club right yeah yeah yeah the smoker's
club that [ __ ] was tight yeah yeah
but that's another story whole another
story whole another day
um all right guys thank you so much this
has been just one long
just smoking weed and talking video
which is fine but like which
is called our pockets yeah i guess you
can say that
uh ratchet man omar ragitone thank you
man
appreciate it thank you for coming thank
you for uh
bringing the weed i needed i had no weed
and i had no time before the show
go can you pick this weed up on the way
i was like yeah yeah i got you
um yeah links in the description guys
appreciate you dude
thank you appreciate you thank you thank
you guys uh for everyone
out there if you're driving please be
safe thank you so much baby sinclair
steven seagal
[Laughter]
we're just gonna talk [ __ ] we have og
here to talk every eight minutes go
yeah brody that's right weasel tips and
that's it
that's all he'll say and i'm like have
you roll joints
[Music]
[Laughter]
guys thank you so much for watching uh
what to do brody
exact that's exactly what he called me
after i called you yeah
but you already picked it uh weed up at
the shop brody what do you need
oh [ __ ] i can literally bet myself money
on what he's gonna say opening the
[ __ ] i mean answering the phone
there's three things he's gonna say it's
[ __ ] little oh what's up what's up
oh my little me oh you're getting big
like shut the [ __ ]
up
before we keep going and stuff all right
guys thank you so much for watching if
you're in the car please be careful if
you're at home chill with your friends
thank you for making this part of your
day this has been the dope as usual
podcast
talk about life drugs accomplishments
and everything in between
oh and problems but today was a lot of
uh just fun i i didn't think of anything
that was bad that was fun
well that was a good episode so don't do
drugs [ __ ] you
thank you guys so much for watching
drugs i appreciate it for marty
ratchet man and i have a dope ass day yo
do you remember that video of that guy
getting arrested like you want any drugs
yeah what are drugs yeah or what is
drugs that's what he says
what is drugs oh we'll trip out that
[ __ ] guy
i know this armenian guy in
normandy where i lived where my mom
he is uh that was one of his uncle's
homies
they know that man you should see this
video this guy's like this
is fighting his life that happened was
amazing
he had a bunch of pills
that's why yo the cops are you have any
drugs on he goes
no what is drugs the way he says it's so
[ __ ] funny bro i mean it's hysterical
what is drugs
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect